es el día llamado del puerto seguro hora
de que donald trump deje de tratar de
torcer el escenario por ley todos los
estados de eeuu tienen que resolver toda
disputa electoral y certificar los
resultados seis días antes de que el
colegio electoral se reúna para votar
por el próximo presidente un día antes
de la fecha límite
georgia se certificó los resultados de
la elección en ese estado y confirmó la
victoria de bayern tras un segundo
recuento solicitado por la campaña del
prd ya hemos contado los votos legales
tres veces y los resultados permanecen
sin cambios
change and other sé que hay gente que
está convencida de que la elección
estuvo plagada de problemas pero la
evidencia la evidencia real los hechos
muestran otra historia
en la votación de noviembre byd en gano
georgia por un margen de tan sólo 12.000
votos un 0 25 por ciento aunque el
recuento final mostró discrepancias de
cerca de 800 votos estos no fueron
suficientes para cambiar el resultado
alegando un vasto fraude
la campaña de trump interpuso docenas de
demandas en estados en disputa desde
arizona hasta michigan y pensilvania
buscando descartar cerca de 6 millones
de votos
si miras a nevada que está cambiando muy
rápido o arizona ustedes vieron esos
números salir ayer encontramos un fraude
masivo y también en otros estados
esta es probablemente la elección más
fraudulenta que jamás se haya visto en
la mayoría de las demandas han sido
rechazadas o retiradas por falta de
evidencia todos los estados impugnados
por thom ya certificaron los resultados
allanando el camino para que los 538
electores voten el próximo lunes
joe biden tiene 306 votos electorales y
donald trump 232